elle va dire poutine annoncent donc que
la libération de mario palette avec
succès en effet pour l'instant du côté
de kiev on n'a pas de déclaration
officielle pourquoi le président russe
lui s'exprime aujourd'hui maintenant
alors que mario paul n'est pas contrôlée
en tout cas pas complètement à 100% pour
le moment parce qu'on est aussi dans une
communication pour la russie et que du
coup parler de marioupol c'est à faire
état d'un fait côté russe c'est vrai que
on sait que la ville en soi a été
aujourd'hui quasiment rasé donc allé
effectivement quasiment tenu par les
russes la poche de résistance elle est
sûre cette usine qui jouxte qui fait
partie de la ville et qui est en soi
comme un quartier à côté donc il
communique là dessus parce que ça lui
permet d'avoir d'abord un succès annoncé
en politique intérieure il a dans le
viseur les célébrations du 9 mai qui
sont une grande bataille pour la russie
parce que ça commémore la seconde guerre
mondiale donc il faut qu'il annonce un
succès lycée qui remonte le moral des
personnes quelque part ça commence à
faire rentrer aussi l'idée qui est bien
une guerre qui est en train de se jouer
au niveau de sa politique intérieure et
puis peut être aussi que ça va lui
permettre de dire qu'il va libérer un
certain nombre de troupes qui du coup
vont pouvoir aller au delà de mario paul
et faire cette fameuse mise en tenaille
du noma ce qu'il espérait tant par le
sud alors revenons sur cette poche de
résistance qui se trouvent dans l' usine
das d'azov ce talent oui alors c'est
intéressant parce que en fait il a
clairement dit qu'il ne fallait pas
donner l'assaut et là c'est une
terminologie militaire parce que on se
retrouve sur un complexe métallurgique
très particulier on n'est pas sur une
simple petite cuisine on est sur une
usine qui a été construite à l'époque
soviétique il y avait quarante mille
salariés qui pouvaient y travaillent et
48 voyez ça fait quand même comme une
petite ville est en fête à en dessous de
cette usine vous avez toute une série
des tâches qui fonctionne par des
tunnels qui relient les étages les uns
aux autres et comme tout a été construit
pendant la guerre froide tout ça a été
construit en abris anti armes atomiques
donc c'est extrêmement résistant une
grande partie d du métro russe ou du
micro trop et craignait d'ailleurs à
cette crainte qui étaient là pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale l'arme atomique
à mairie cannes qu'elle est tombée
dessus une fois que vous avez vidé cette
usine et que vous voyez qu'elle est
gigantesque presque sur 8 km ha et que
vous avez des combattants qui sont à
l'intérieur avec tout ce système étages
qui résiste aux bombes parce que ça ne
sert à rien de larguer des bombes par le
dessus ça veut dire que si vous allez
les déloger vous êtes sur un combat qui
va être un combat assez spectaculaire
parce que ils n'ont pas les plans donc
on ne sait pas où des babouches les
tunnels donc vous pouvez vous dire que
vous avez nettoyer une pièce et puis
finalement vous allez être attaqué par
derrière
donc il ne les amène pas au combat c'est
à dire qu'il pense à protéger des
soldats russes il ne veut plus avoir des
soldats russes morts après qu'est ce
qu'il va faire en terminologie militaire
quand on demande à des experts et 10
quand on se trouve devant ce genre de
situation on l'a déjà fait dans le cadre
du liban dans ces calanques houle du
ciment par exemple dans les tunnels ce
qui du coup ferme en fait les entrées et
donc isole complètement les gens qui
sont à l'intérieur soit ça soit larmes
chimiques mais on ne voit pas
aujourd'hui le dit mr poutine utiliser
l'armé chimique sur un terrain qui a
déjà en fait tilter gagner donc c'est
quelque part c'est ça alors est-ce qu'il
va les laisser filer est-ce qu'il va
gérer les choses différemment mais on
comprend mieux pourquoi ce qu'il dit on
fait le tour de cette usine mais on ne
donne pas la sau merci armelle